are you in a state of happiness right
now do you live in the happiest place on
earth no we're not talking about
Disneyland we're talking about Alaska
okay so it may not be the happiest place
on earth
but according to a new poll it's the
happiest state in America according to
the Gallup poll the top ten list of
happiest days also includes Hawaii South
Dakota Wyoming Montana Colorado and
Nebraska Utah New Mexico and Texas so
are you guys surprised that the two
happiest places in America aren't
attached to the rest of America do you
think there's a connection between being
far away from America in Alaska and
Hawaii and happiness what's going on
they're doing yeah well I'll just tell
you about when I was one time I spent
New Year's Eve I was working in New
Year's Eve in Fairbanks Alaska because
let's face it I have a great agent it
was 42 below zero yeah 42 below thank
old that's what it has to warm up 70
degrees just a [ __ ] freeze yeah
that's cold
right and so I don't I think they're so
happy just because when the Sun comes
out in June it's such a big deal maybe
they took that survey in June right when
the Sun is out 24 hours a day so it
seems like if you look at this the list
of those states
it's where there's the least populated
states and where people live five
Montana Nebraska New Mexico you can't
see another person for days right
there's only like four people in mind
yeah and they're all Chinese are yes
exactly
there's less people in months in Montana
we're Wyoming for the Janey's lives yeah
then there are in my congressional
district and Pasadena so there's less
people in the whole goddamn state which
is why the Senate is unrepresented all
disproportionately giving more power to
smaller states that's another clip yeah
I like what you subtly fact-check me
there it's Wyoming where the Chinese are
from not man tactics oh I just want to
know if the Alaska poll was taken before
or after Sarah Palin whoa do you think
they're happier after laughter yeah
they're happier posed yeah so what is
that so the weather thing I think is
really interesting because I definitely
am hugely affected by the weather I am
much happier now in California than I
was in New York was I wake up and it's
sunny almost all the time but we have
one in two it's Alaska and Ho
why so obviously weather doesn't have
that much to do with it for a lot of
people right no and I didn't seem to
make much sense when I was looking at
the states that were the happiest in
terms of being it didn't it I go to this
the the unhappiest state made a lot of
sense yeah that was West Virginia right
and I've been to West Virginia a lot of
backwards I can't yes-no and I spent a
lot of time in that area I get it
I drove through West Virginia not too
long ago maybe like I need it's like
it's scared that's almost like being in
like The Walking Dead gotta yeah there
are some parts yeah I remember in West
Virginia they had some roads on the sign
about not littering they rhymed
yeah matically incorrect ah so I could
get it so what do you make a real
calculation side of this because also
these are not populous places as you
said but yet we all want to move to
cities that's where we get [ __ ] done
that's where a lot of these states
people stay put yeah where they're from
so there's a sense of family there's a
sense of community there's a sense of
belonging I think when you tend to be
more transient and you move to cities
like New York or Los Angeles it's
probably a lot harder to make that
community because I think this happiness
scale was based on a lot of different
factors yeah so part of it probably is
feeling like you have a home in a place
right and I think I would imagine that
if you're from some of these less
populous states and you choose to stay
hey that's the only world you know right
you don't travel as much you don't see
what else is out there and be you have a
real sense of community within that
small space right so a lot of it also
probably to do with how people define
happiness so if you are just someone
that wants to work all day and work work
work then you could live in a city
probably and be very happy but if you're
somebody that wants to breathe fresh air
perhaps you might be happier in Hawaii
or something like that yeah you know
depending again is that what they choose
to consider happiness and I think if
those people who are in those
unpopulated States who have a fear of
the rest of the world right oh I don't
want to go to I remember I was touring
unpopulated Saskatoon Saskatchewan
Canada 20 years ago whatever and
everybody was there oh my god you're
from Los Angeles oh yeah you ever been
it's great
oh no you get stabbed like everyone sis
what have raised half the city of LA's
walk around with knives and the other
halves walking around what's
yeah that's what that's all I can't you
go you're gonna get stabbed everybody
can stab everyone yeah so that's how
people feel about so I think it's that I
think it's kind of people validating
their choice to be afraid of the world
saying yeah I like it of course so why
everybody loves away everybody no no but
you know what I do know someone who
lives there who doesn't love it because
they feel like they're kind of trapped
they can't go really yeah what a great
place to be trapped I'm trapped in there
you know but it's very expensive
there's a lot of traffic yes you don't
have a lot of options like once you're
right there you're there I mean look i
I've never been Hawaii of all places and
I'm sure I would love it because I love
the beach in the Sun and all that good
stuff but I had this conversation with
somebody it's the sphere of fear and
it's this feeling of being confined and
not being able to drive to another state
yeah I sleep I ever had in my life was
in Maui I was falsely but midnight wake
up at 8:00 a.m. straight through never
felt better in my entire life I couldn't
believe how good I felt yeah when I was
there to your point about Saskatoon and
Saskatchewan up in Canada I did the
Calgary Comedy Festival a couple years
ago really and all of the comedian's
were always making jokes about
Saskatchewan like that was like their
go-to like IVA Hicks in Saskatchewan but
I met a couple people from Saskatchewan
and they seemed great like happy they're
all pleasant wonderful people so I don't
notice happy me in the city or statue on
I don't know anyway let us know what you
think in the comments right down below
anyway thanks for watching guys and
we'll do it again